la scène la joconde le château du clos
lucé rassemble dans une galerie
virtuelle inédite 17 chef-d'oeuvre de
léonard de vinci dans un ballet
savamment mis en scène où les croquis
les citations permettent d'appréhender
le processus de création du génie
italien grâce à l'expression de son
travail préparatoire à travers ses
croquis ses dessins ses essais jusqu'au
chef d'oeuvre à l'aboutissement du
chef-d'oeuvre
eh bien on comprend comment léonard
travail est observé dessinée apprendre
comprendre ça a été le fait de tout son
apprentissage le nar de vinci n'a pas
été à l'école
il a tout observer de la nature tout
observer du mouvement peintre ingénieur
inventeur de machines volantes léonard
de vinci s'intéresse à toutes les
architectures
il est aussi un précurseur en matière
d'urbanisme
c'est l'autre facette à découvrir dans
cette toute nouvelle exposition du clos
du 6 au 14 185 il ya eu une énorme perf
à milan et
et donc léonard fait partie de ceux qui
réfléchissent avec les ebit de la ville
à ce qu'on pourrait faire de mieux donc
une ville idéale à milan une cité idéale
que l'architecte modélisant france pour
la ville de romorantin dans le loir et
cher à romorantin léonard va reprendre
finalement c'est sa grande passion
urbanistique milanaise c'est à dire que
effectivement ils pensent la ville en
termes de canaux en termes d'évacuation
des déchets avec des des éléments
souterrain des galeries souterraines
qu'on a retrouvé d'ailleurs un roman
tout récemment la mort de l'inventeur en
15/100 19 met un terme à la difficulté
de la cité léonard de vinci reste
inégalé dans l'histoire pour sa soif de
connaissance intarissable